because Critics on the right have noted
that New York City is a sanctuary City
and this migrant crisis comes with that
territory what do you say to those who
think uh you relinquish your right to
complain about the stresses it places on
your city because of that well I I think
that those comments coming from those
far-right trump-like Republicans who are
continue to try to distort the reality
that we do not have real immigration
reform that we should allow a true
decompression strategy or protect our
borders in the right way no one who
created this decades ago took into
account that we were talking about
hundreds of thousands of people
potentially coming to coming to the city
guys nobody who thought of this stuff
thought people might actually show up
how was I supposed to know if we said
we're a sanctuary City come here we
won't kick you out whose fault is it
really of course it's the mean Trump
Mega Republicans and the people not
taking care of the Border